[Musique]
le ton est donné aujourd'hui on
manifeste en s'amusant
au programme jeux de massacre pêche à la
ligne
mais on ne perd pas de vue l'objectif
principal sont décidément non au grand
canal les rares hier qu'il faut pas
faire le grand canal d'alsace ava que ça
va enlever l'eau bien prétendre au mont
serein privés d'eau parce que ça pollue
l'eau quand ça inondera bas ma maison
comme la balle va être amendé
donc tu es contre ça fait maintenant
vingt ans qu'il se bat contre le grand
canal 20 ans de manif 20 ans de pétition
contre ce monstre de béton qui relierait
le rhône au rhin en détruisant la vallée
du lot ici le grand canal c'est un peu
comme un serpent de mer a forcé d'en
parler on n'y croit plus vraiment et
pourtant la semaine dernière
décidé de financer le projet le décret
d'application est imminent sont capables
sur des projets comme ça de se
rassembler des démons tristan médias
l'edf bruit chez magnan place au
gouvernement nous faire la ceinture de
tous les côtés me demande où ils
trouveraient cet argent pour faire ce
canal ou alors il ya des questions
od quand même les opposants au projet
s'appuie maintenant sur une étude dite
sérieuse le grand canal ne serait pas
rentable c'est le conseil scientifique
du comité de bassin rhône méditerranée
qu'ils affirment cette fois ci ce sont
uniquement des écolos rigolos comme on
vit habituellement avec une nuance de
mépris ce sans même les savants en
blouse blanche les les scientifiques et
les les personnes responsables en
costard cravate qui montent au créneau
pour dire que c'est un projet qui ne
tient pas la route
aujourd'hui avec vous on a fait la fête
mais les époux vont maintien et après
m
[Musique]